so
historically i'd say the web platform
has really been this kind of clutch it's
grown organically into
more or less a mess it has no sense of
cohesion
most of the apis that we have to deal
with have been poorly designed by
c plus developers and they write them in
this binding layer called idl
which was originally meant for corba if
you can believe that
um and and you know even more so than
just the the problems with what we
already have
there's the things we don't have there's
the major gaps in what we can do
on the web compared to native apps
compared to desktop apps compared to
mobile apps
and even for those things we can do we
end up doing them mostly by drowning
ourselves
in large javascript libraries that
polyfill like this functionality that we
need or let us create a new select
element so that we just
we can style it so why does this happen
what's
what's the problem with the web with
this platform that we've
we all love and work on well the problem
is really
in the process i claim and the deal is
that generally
when we introduce new features into our
web platform
it's done via this this complicated
waterfall this
months or years of mailing list
standardization where
people debate to no end like the minute
details of how
exactly the perfect api should work from
their perspective
and then they write it down in prose or
in this this web idl interface
definition language and they're
in the end they're really driven by this
scenario solving idea where they say oh
we have this problem we need to solve it
let's
let's throw some c bus plus over the
wall attach a tag name to it
and then say oh here you go here's your
api so we get this fundamental
capability
that we want but instead of getting it
kind of exposed in a way we want to use
we get this high level thing that just
burrows down
from some tag down to c plus
we can't customize it we can't work with
it in the way that we'd want to if we'd
written it ourselves in javascript
and all this time you know you
eventually get this thing as as
troublesome as it may be well you try
and use it and you end up telling the
standards bodies wow it's it's kind of a
huge mess and it solves half your
problems and
half the time i mean indexeddb is kind
of the quintessential example of huge
mess but
this is just a general issue with most
of the apis today
and yet despite all of this like somehow
as a platform we've we've done
just okay i mean well okay maybe better
than okay maybe we're the most
successful platform ever
how did we manage to do that um well
there's a few
few techniques that we've used as a
community um
we've we've wrapped we've said you know
your api
sucks let me build a better one um
jquery is the most famous example of
this obviously but we also do this
amazing thing
which is called trolley filling we're
saying
wouldn't it be cool if we could select
elements in the dom using css selectors
and thus sizzle is born or wouldn't it
be cool if we could create custom tags
that had their own behaviors just like
normal html tags and thus something like
angularjs is born so these are these are
prolly fills right like a
probably this will fill in for the
future of of our language
and of our platform and eventually they
do
um but but sometimes that isn't enough
sometimes we need to transpile
right our language itself fails us so we
create things like sas
which extend css with some pretty darn
obvious features
or coffeescript that just gives us a
more expressive language to
to work in these have their problems but
but in the end they help us
a lot towards a more expressive platform
finally in one case that's particularly
close to my heart you know we even built
an interoperable standard among a bunch
of implementers of a certain pattern
promises
from the ground up but i mean in general
for all of these things that we do
we we say we do them because we need our
platform to be better
and so we need to make it better
ourselves
so the extensible web manifesto is this
thing we put together
you know a few months ago saying that
the standards bodies
are really ready to do their part in
this this game this
platform that we're trying to create you
know until now we as the community have
been shouldering all the work we've been
writing our massive javascript libraries
or transpiling
just to reinvent basic functionality and
get what we want
but there's a better way where we work
together with these these
bodies and these implementers towards
the future and so
you know one way of putting this you
know a good analogy i think is what the
standards bodies have realized
is that the web platform is our language
but like all languages
it must evolve and there's two ways that
this primarily happens
two ways in which we extend the web
forward as we say so we need to extend
our basic vocabulary our basic pieces of
this language
and the second part is we need to start
incorporating slang
i want to go over some of the things
like what does this mean
when i say extending our vocabulary
there's really two key ideas here
first we need to explain the features of
the platform
that are already there so you know going
back to the language analogy
wouldn't it be weird if we had these
compound words like sci-fi
but we didn't actually have words for
science or fiction
well that's that's kind of how it is on
the web today if some standards body
maybe the french making up words
worldwide consortium
just handed us the word like sandpaper
but we never actually had a word for
sand or
paper individually that's that's the
problem we face today where we have
these high level features but they're
not built from anything
that we could actually reuse and create
new words out of create new
new things out of we just have all this
magic compound concepts
and the second part of extending our
vocabulary is giving you new low-level
features that you can use
right if you wanted to invent the word
sci-fi somebody better have come up with
the concepts of science and fiction
first right and just like that on the
web
there's a lot of things we just don't
have words for and we're slowly getting
there
but still native apps are hurting us
here they're saying we have the ability
to access this device feature we can do
the clipboard but you can't so we need
to extend our
platform in a way that's that takes
these into account
so with this in mind like what are what
kind of initiatives are underway
to give us this this new vocabulary this
new feature of the web platform what
has the extensible web philosophy kind
of yielded and what can you look forward
to
well the first one the most fundamental
gap in the platform i think
is is how these darn tag things work and
custom tags is a feature that tries to
explain that
because think about it right now you
feed a string containing some angle
brackets
into the browser and then they get
turned into these javascript objects
with these wonderful apis and we call
that
the dom how does that even work right
like
what what tags how do they work well
custom tags explain this process they
say you register
the mapping of tag names to element
prototypes with the browser
and then when the html parser gets its
string it says oh
well i see this tag let me give you this
prototype
and this is great this is this is the
democratization of html essentially this
is saying that you are now
on the same level as browser vendors
when you want to create new semantics
and new widgets for your web and what's
even great better about this
right is you have no more of these crazy
widget libraries with their own weird
semantics no more jquery ui with its
option magic function that sometimes is
a setter and sometimes as a getter and
sometimes calls a function
no more dojo digits if you remember
those no more bootstrap craziness
div class equals button no more win js
with its win control property off which
all the magic happens
right like just you have tags and they
turn into elements
and they behave like normal dom things
with getters and setters and properties
and
methods and just like you'd expect so
now we have the ability to do this in
our platform and this is coming
but even you know what about all the
existing tags right half the reason we
have these widget libraries these jquery
uis and so on
is just so you can create your own
custom select because
otherwise you can't style it you can't
you can't customize it
i mean in general this is a problem with
our existing platform right we have
these tags these magic tags like select
or input or or details or video
with these pieces that you can't really
reach even something as simple as li
has this bullet which is like where did
that come from
you know what's the explanation for that
there's this extra stuff the browser's
doing
but you have no idea how well so the
concept that we've come up to explain
this with to
explain this is the shadow dom the idea
that there's a dom
behind the dom that you can normally
access where all these hidden little
pieces the the controls the placeholders
the bullets
whatever that's where they live and
what's great is that once we have a
basis for these hidden parts of the dom
in in reality
instead of in c bus plus magic land then
we can hook into styling and rebuilding
and extending these controls
instead of having to rebuild them
entirely in javascript with all the
accessibility issues and
behavior issues and cross-platform
issues that come along with that
and so i you know a couple of days ago i
was researching for this
and i saw this this beautiful beautiful
line
on the blink dev form which i want to
just take a moment to read to you which
says
i'm working on transitioning the select
element from a custom renderer to shadow
dom
tears of joy guys you know after so many
years
of having this this horrible select
element and having the designers be like
no you need to create a custom select
soon soon we're going to be able to
style select
and customize it and make a combo box
and everything will be beautiful
so a good example of both adding new
capabilities
and explaining the old ones is web audio
because web audio is about new
capabilities in a large part you can do
fundamentally new things like we've
already seen a few talks today on
positional audio audio synthesis really
great stuff
but if you remember the first time audio
got on the web was back in 2009 we had
this audio tag
which is kind of the quintessential
throw some simplest magic over the wall
to you
given this high level construct with
limited customizability and just like
all these this restrictions right that's
from the extensible web perspective the
audio tag should essentially be
explained in terms of web audio
and that's the direction we're trying to
go we're trying to say all these
you know high level things we need a way
to explain them and audio is just a
great example of that
and more generally for new capabilities
we're getting a lot of these in the
platform more and more as we go a lot of
mozilla's firefox os work is pushing the
boundaries here
saying we need to have all these
capabilities and so things like full
screen notifications geolocation and so
on
this is the kind of thing that we're
going to get parity with native apps
and what's cool is that we've
prioritized these things we've said you
know
the extensible web is all about saying
these are the most important things to
get in the platform because these are
things we cannot do
we don't need to design a perfect new
database api
we need to design you know full screen
finally you know the last piece of
extending our vocabulary is extending
the base language javascript that we
work in
and the features coming up in ecmascript
6 and exclusive seven
are going to give us these capabilities
and so they're kind of subtle
but like for example in equiscript six
there's a lot of work going in to make
sure the built-ins things like array or
date or so on
are extensible so instead of having to
rebuild the entire date parsing logic
just because you need to be able to
format dates you'll be able to do you
know class
moment extends date you know instead of
uh
and and so proxies is another good
example of this you know things like
amber or backbone or so on you know they
all need this this custom object model
that can intercept all the gets and sets
and method calls
well right now they end up rebuilding a
parallel object model
you know saying oh you have to use dot
get dot set and
all this crazy stuff well proxies will
actually be able to
use normal javascript semantics to allow
you to build your own objects of the
type you need
and in es7 we'll have object.observe
and which allows you to observe
arbitrary properties of an object
perfect for data binding
and similarly weak references which is a
great thing that we'll be able to use to
bind view models and models and so on
together and not have to worry about
cleaning up after ourselves
in this in this way and so now that we
have this capable platform right with
all these new low-level capabilities
and with our existing capabilities you
know composed out of low-level
primitives
we'll be able to stop rebuilding the
entire platform just to customize one
piece
but there's one thing left you know the
second half of the extensible web
which is that we need to tighten the
feedback loop between developers and
standards bodies and in short we need to
incorporate the slang that you guys are
already building
over and over into the platform itself
because think about it you've built all
these great things out of low-level
tools
but now you're downloading megabytes of
javascript or transpiling from some
other
you know non-non-standard language uh
and fracture in the community you know
because you need to get your base
platform up and running
this is why almost every web page uses
jquery you know the platform hasn't
stepped up to the plate
and incorporated jquery's innovations
back in but we're trying to change this
too
right so so one of the greatest you know
easiest examples
of this philosophy of saying you know
we've been doing this for a long time
let's do it you know let's put it in the
standard is the template tag
you know everybody knows script type
equals text x handlebars or whatever
right like all these these crazy custom
script tags that you use to put your
templates
well we finally recognize that this
pattern is something that we actually
need support for in the platform it
needs to be optimized and fast and
native and injection proof
and that's why we have this template tag
which is now it's now in the spec
it's being implemented in browsers
you know even more like higher level
something like dialogue right you know
jquery ui dialogue has been around in a
venerable workhorse and a pain in my ass
like for many many years
but it's the best thing out there well
wouldn't it be nice if we actually
recognize that this is a common pattern
and put it in the platform so that's
exactly what is in there now we have
this dialog tag represents a dialog has
open close result return value like
we we can actually say oh
developers are doing this over and over
why don't we do it for them
so that's what we're trying to do here
you know turning to css
right like these basic basic things like
like variables or reset style sheets
or nesting of of you know when you
author your css well
there's actually the people in charge of
css have realized
we need to start doing this we need to
incorporate this we need our base
language not to be just a compile target
but actually something that's reasonable
to write in so there's specs you know
variables
and hierarchies you know borrowing from
sas but also unset
which is this ability to basically
create reset style sheets in one line
star property onset
right and so that's that's the basic
idea there
pointer events a good example
microsoft's been pushing this very hard
but they're pushing it for a good reason
because we've got all these libraries
abstracting away
saying oh you know both touch and mouse
are pointers and when somebody clicks or
touches i want to create an event well
of course that seems pretty obvious in
retrospect
but that's what pointer events are
giving you because and now we don't have
to create those libraries unifying them
and unifying these concepts
and you know of course something very
close to my heart is promises
you know when you have a pattern that's
been adopted by jquery
by dojo by angular by ember by win.js
and by yui
maybe it's time to put these in the
platform maybe it's time to recognize we
have consensus on an async primitive
and that now we can build on top of that
so what's next what's next for this
extensible web philosophy that
has brought us all these goodies and is
is still bringing them to us well
this is just a sneak peek but you know
perhaps the most important thing that we
need to get right next
is streams so we have all these crazy
abstractions with great names on the
platform right now
great interfaces great apis like file
reader you know read as array buffer
you who xmlhp request best api ever
you have to pass true not to block the
browser um
get user media right like there's just
another example
some other way of getting a streaming
streaming set of data
post message you're posting these
messages across iframe boundaries
you know you have to build your own
streaming protocol on top of that
um object urls which are i think one of
the greatest
most ingenious but also most disgusting
hacks in the history of the web platform
where you're like oh
i have this this url representing a
stream of data from from
the webcam or whatever and i'm going to
set image.src equal to that
and we have media streams which is this
new way of saying oh well stream data is
a video tag
i mean it seems like just like with
promises we're missing a very important
piece of slang here
that the platform has already created
and node.js has led the way
but there's a lot of lessons we can
learn from node.js's mistakes
so to get something that will work
really well with the web platform and
unify
all these crazy different concepts and
then make our life easier
because in the end we want to be able to
take all these different sources you
know
urls which we fetch data from camera
data binary payloads which are in the
cache already
we want to pipe them into different
syncs we want to put them in image tags
we're going to put them in video tags
audio
tags we want to put them across the
boundary to other iframes
we want to have custom ways of consuming
them and transforming them and
building things in the browser so that's
that's i think one of the most exciting
and most fundamental pieces missing
but you know another good example is
something you know the basic act of
doing an http request right because
think about how much complexity we have
built into that system in the browser
right now
there's cross domain protection there's
redirect following
there's there's the actual
deserialization process you know if you
want to access the raw bites that's not
as easy as you'd hope
there's cookie jars right maintaining
and storing where your cookies go
there's caches you know does this stuff
go in the cash or does it get pulled
directly from the website what we need
to do you know to provide
developers with what they really need to
build the kind of servers we want
and and you know websites we want is to
provide the basic building block just
the fetch
and then all of these different features
of the platform are just options to
fetch or layers on top of fetch
and so that's what we'll be trying to do
you know is provide the correct
primitive not something as high level as
xhr or as
you know with one semantics for script
tags and one for link tags
we want something like this another and
this is one i've been pushing
um because i ask around in chat rooms
you know what are you missing
and people tell me over and over is we
need we need zlib support we need gzip
we need zip
and so so there's active investigation
going on how are we going to get
gzip exposed to you guys so that you can
actually start g-zipping in the browser
right this is something you can write in
js
and people have probably filled this
they've created apis
that will will use binary data and
actually do compression in the browser
which is awesome
but the browser's already got some
people plus sitting there ready to do
this for you
that should just be exposed um
and and perhaps my favorite because this
has just happened a couple days ago
is class elements extends array this is
the new node list
no more stupid you know oh for each is
not a function it's like
no now we can actually have something
that extends array has array semantics
you can do map
filter for each whatever and that's what
will return
and what else i mean i mean what do we
need guys what's preventing you from
building the web apps of your dreams
well
i want you guys to tell us so so get
involved right
and the best thing you can do to get
involved you know just just
off the bat with your existing skills
is prolly fill okay so there's only so
much standardization bandwidth to go
around you might think that there's
these people up in their
their ivory towers at mozilla and google
and microsoft like
ah i will type out specs all day turns
out there's actually
they don't have that kind of time right
so if you can create a de facto standard
like jquery
or an open specification like promises a
plus the world is waiting
for you to take on that and to show us
what the web should look like
so for example if you wanted to figure
out what a zlib api for browsers look
like
the best thing that you can do is first
learn what the constraints are and what
the use cases are and not just your use
case not just node.js
use case and not just your your i love
whatever use case right you need to
figure out what are
we the problems that everybody is trying
to solve that'll make this a good
general purpose solution
once you have that then you can design
an api
and a library to probably fill this gap
in the platform something that kind of
shows off
how is this going to work and then the
last step and this is what i think a lot
of kind of like the
the node.js developers don't do they're
off in their little world saying oh
we'll build this awesome thing
you need to evangelize its use you need
to ship it
to everyone so that everybody sees oh
this is the perfect way to do zlib
this is the way that this is the great
api this is general purpose
low level exactly what we want and so
when everybody recognized this is the
clear solution for how to do zlib in the
browser
it's going to be really easy for the
browser vendors to just say oh
let's put that in the standard done
and i wanted to emphasize that in
general this this extensible web
philosophy has teeth
okay it's not just a bunch of guys wrote
a document
and and now all the implementers are
going to ignore them
or all the standards writers are going
to ignore them so what's what's cool is
that the the w3c
technical architecture group which is
kind of the over the the standards by
the body overseeing all the standards
bodies
um it had four seats go up for
re-election recently and four
four reformers as they call themselves
were elected at once so yeah these
people are yehuda katz
alex russell marcus casares and anna van
kester
and so the extensible web philosophy is
really something they they're
pushing and giving this as a mission to
the technical architecture group
you know this is the ultimate technical
body which gives governance and
and guidance to all of the standards and
all the specs that we see
and we've already seen fruit from this
from this technical architecture group
overhaul they've given some really great
feedback you know
mediating between developers and between
their own understanding of javascript
idioms
to the web audio group trying to make
that a more idiomatic and more easy to
use and
and more low-level spec um
and generally just make it less magical
and more javascript
and what's also cool is that all their
work is being done on github
and and more and more specs are being
done on github at their urging
so this is happening we're really
starting to get a web that we want a web
that we can participate in
how to make friends and influence
standards bodies more generally
like if you beyond just prolly filling
the kind of thing that you already
you can build libraries today if you
want to be involved in helping the web
succeed
and guide us towards better standards
right then
let's talk okay i mean it's a
complicated subject but this idea of
interfacing with standards bodies and
interfacing with the people who write
standards
is something i've been diving into over
the last half year or so it started with
my promises work
but it's expanded into many other things
you know finding the right approach is
delicate right these people are very
used to you coming onto their mailing
list and saying
let's add a ray.prototype.myfavorite
thing and then
that you just flip the bozo bit and and
they're like oh well who is this guy we
don't need to
like listen to him but if you if you
kind of approach in good faith and have
a used case and
don't have a prideful demeanor they're
really happy to listen
and i've had a few success stories where
i've kind of talked to other developers
through how do you you know what's a
good way to approach this
this problem and how who should you talk
to and and what channel should you use
um in this area already and and by this
time next year i'd love to have a lot
more
and i'll be giving a talk at lxgs with
this title and by the way
so stay tuned if you want to know more
about the exact process
so i finally i want to end on a hopeful
note right because it's easy to think
about all these cool things that i
showed you earlier and all these cool
things that i'd
talk about coming and then go back to
your job and get depressed because you
have to support ie8
or android 2.3 but but that's really
not so bad when you consider the
alternative this is the price we pay
for the open extensible multi-platform
web
as opposed to something like say net
where it's like oh
everybody upgrade from 3.0 to 4.5
sucks if you get left behind that's that
and there's only one of us so
no choice right we need to work through
this collaborative process
cooperative process build a shared
language that we can all
you know use together so in the end the
future is longer than the past
and and i look forward to not only
living in that future but also helping
to shape it
together with all of you that's it
you